josée legault à la question guy michel
david bonsoir bonsoir soit bonsoir à
l'ariana ce soit qui doit ce qui doit
s'en vouloir beaucoup
le député de rivière du loup témiscouata
témiscouata pardon de la cac
josée legault denis tardif bon c'est
exclu lui-même du caucus mais il
l'aurait pas fait qu'il aurait été exclu
de le voir faire était dans une
brasserie collet et ses collègues alors
que message du gouvernement de la cac
c'est et suivez les consignes donc ça
regarde mal
oui parce que c'est pas n'importe quel
député non plus les membres du
gouvernement qui gère cette pandémie
l'eau depuis presque dix mois
ça nous montre aussi parce que l'alcool
avait l'air d'être assez présent qu
savez quand on demandait avant que le
gouvernement sa fermeture des bars et
que l'alcool qui est aussi très
désinhibant on le voit et ce qu'on ce
qu'on voit aussi c'est malheureusement
ce qu'on risque de voir pendant ce temps
des fêtes ou si il y à des choses comme
ça qui se passe déjà il ya des choses
comme ça qu'ils vont continuer de se
passer d'où l'importance salaires cruel
mais d'en faire un exemple
parce que ce qu'il a fait c'était
vraiment de très haut niveau
d'irresponsabilité
le message est passé en tout cas la
règle ou way home soulignant
gouvernement qu'il est expulsé
temporairement du caucus de la caq donc
on peut penser qu'il va réintégrer ses
fonctions dans quelques semaines
quelques mois il un peu sur le banc de
punition un monsieur tardive parce
qu'effectivement on peut pas se
permettre au gouvernement de laisser ça
comme ça oui les bars et les
microbrasseries les restaurants avaient
beau être encore ouvert à
rivière-du-loup jusqu'à ce matin
on a quand même là ce moment-là franchi
certaines règles aux promesses en masque
à l'intérieur de l'établissement on
était très très près de ses collègues et
on a surtout fait l'équivalent d'un
party de bureau puisque c'étaient des
collègues qui semble-t-il étaient des
employés de son association de
circonscription or françois legault
avait dit quoi il ya trois jours fait
pas de porte et de bureaux dans commence
à être difficile de ne pas sévir pour le
premier c'est la proximité en fait c'est
la proximité
michel avait été acquis les images tulle
a absolument tout le nombre d'interdits
vous savez avait jamais circulé dans des
rumeurs de remaniement mais que tu
pourras jamais il est clair monsieur
tarder il a une grosse grosse tache à
son dossier et pour cause
mais au delà de mauvaise exemple parce
que c'est évident c'était épouvantable
mais c'est malheureusement je pense
représentatif de ce qui se passe dans
beaucoup d'endroits où québec
si un député le triche semaine passée ça
imaginez qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
le font
alors c'est comment dire c'est un triste
exemple mais ça reflète une réalité
on peut peut-être entendre c'est très
rapide le ministre la santé qui j'ai
demandé une réaction tout à l'heure on
écoute me suis dit que pour moi c'est
une erreur de jugement puis il rit le il
s'est retiré du caucus je pense que
c'était la seule décision à prendre
écoutez vous faut prêcher par l'exemple
c'est ce qu'on demande aux québécois d'
on sait qu'on est con et année on sait
qu'on a que ça finisse que le vaccin sa
vie il s'est justement pas le temps de
lâcher pis ce comportement leur était
pas acceptable je contactais décidé de
se retirer du caucus entre une attitude
responsable qu'on demande aux gens et la
délation de l'autre côté je vous fais
entendre la mairesse plantes et vous me
direz ce que vous en pensez
au sujet des rassemblements interdits
demandez-vous montréal est d'appeler la
police six lois de la visite chez les
voisins bah écoutez je pense que s'il
on voit plusieurs personnes qui rentrent
dans une résidence
je pense que c'est la chose à faire mais
en même temps faut comprendre que le
spvm ou s'ils vont en ordre de priorité
d'appel savez quoi
moi j'ai vraiment envie de demander ou
montréal et de respecter les règles
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut le bon le
vus alec là après le vent a voulu dire
dans le fond je suis pas sûr qu'on
aimerait qu'ils arrivent mais quand même
alors vous en être là dessus on comprend
l'immense malaise là parce qu'on veut
pas non plus arriver dans un espèce de
de société où tout le monde comme au
printemps dernier le plus la police pour
tous puis pour rien y avait quelqu'un
qu'elle est sur le balcon quelqu'un
donné un cadeau qui ont appelé la police
le sait pas une ambiance très agréable
en même temps c'est vrai aussi que si
votre voisin reçoit dix quinze vingt
personnes puis qui met des gens en
danger qui propage l'épidémie il faut
aussi être conscient que une bonne idée
d'appeler la police mais le jugement de
chacun entre les deux pour un politicien
c'est difficile là était quand même pas
pour dire non à + poids la police si un
parent et à côté de chez vous question
le c'est une bonne question qui la
connaissent et un peu puisque un point
dire oh non non vous faites vous encore
appelé personne m'a même temps appelé la
police ya quelque chose qu'on aime
paladares bien sûr de société où les
gens vont commencer assez ce pionner oui
exactement puis je termine juste en
disant qu' il ya quand même le tout sur
des nuances par exemple on peut recevoir
une personne seule à l'intérieur de sa
bulle familiale ça va être permis donc
pas parce que quelqu'un rentre chez son
voisin qui fait importer non plus donc
qui tout cela dans les petites nuances
comme seul pour les corps policiers ça
soit pas une période particulièrement
facile
michel david oui c'est une question
piège évidemment à l'époque a répondu
madame madame plantes
valeur sûre de vouloir être ailleurs
maintenant et comme dit avec lilly en
question du jugement là dedans les
voisins on les connaît souvent leurs
habitudes alors ils savent très bien ce
qui se passe mais je reprends par
exemple la question vous avez posées au
ministre dubé tantôt si on sait qu'il ya
des gens à côté de chez nous qui ont
deux enfants qui habitent à l'extérieur
ils n'ont pas le droit de venir tous les
deux et là on les voit jouer tous les
deux à noël à moins que vous vouliez
régler des comptes avec votre passé avec
lequel s'étend chicane pour d'autres
raisons
savoie 10e dénoncé sa damas si vous
voyez quelqu'un une réunion familiale on
peut enfin les petites tricheries
patrice je pense d'ailleurs on entendait
des traiteurs dans des reportages
semaine dernière dire qu'ils ont des
commandes au p 15 20 30 personnes à une
adresse qui savent pas trop quoi faire
avec ça de même sur la mairesse plantes
oui c'est clair qu'elle voulait être
ailleurs lève beaucoup hésité avant de
répondre et elle a répondu finalement
plus comme une citoyenne et qui est je
pense que comme mais reste parce que
comme comme mère est la métropole c'est
sûr que le dire aux jambes écouter
appelé la police si vous voyez quelque
chose quoi qu'elle a donnée quand même
un exemple où c'était justement pour
petits mais bon plusieurs plusieurs
voitures ou plusieurs personnes moi
j'aurais été plus autonome plus sage si
la directrice de la santé publique de
montréal madame hélène royer avait fait
cet appel locaux à la délation mais à la
prudence et à la prudence solidaire
parce que si vous voyez quelque chose de
vraiment dangereux
ben qu'est ce que vous voulez un moment
donné il faut que vous fassiez quelque
chose en étanchant davis est en
croissance et vos voisins qui font leurs
parts et qui vont s'infecter peut-être
vous
les croisés deux jours plus tard à
l'épicerie ou à la pharmacie parce que
c'est sûr qu'on va avoir dix voire de
peu plus ou moins donc c'était juste mal
dit mais c'était comme un appel à la
responsabilité mais encore une fois je
pense que s'arrêter bien que ça vienne
de l'adducteur droit
très bien dernier volet les sondages où
on est où en sommes-nous sondage léger
gens ne m'ont rien intentions de vote
des québécois
on va y aller en ordre le fédéral et on
voit que c'est intéressant parce que
c'est au québec le sondage là mais les
intentions de vote des québécois fédérer
très divisés 33% les libéraux en son
temps première place mais c'est très
serré le bloc en deuxième position et
les conservateurs qui ont repris un peu
sont à 21
alec castonguay c'est intéressant parce
que c'est un un champ de bataille qui
équipe a décidé on est grosso modo entre
le bloc québécois et le parti libéral du
canada dans la marge d'erreur depuis
plusieurs mois le temps en temps ses 33
33 34 32 euro s'échange un peu la tête
mais grosso modo on est au coude à coude
entre les deux parties là la nouveauté
de ce sont la jeunesse et le parti
conservateur c'est une auto à 21% qui
est une hausse assez importante à
l'extérieur de la marge d'erreur huit
points depuis le début de l'automne et
grosso modo quand on regarde sa part
fait très très mal à justin trudeau ça
tire un peu plus le bloc québécois vers
le bas et ça on s'en doutait depuis un
petit moment il ya beaucoup d'électeurs
particulièrement à l'extérieur de
montréal pour qui le choix vont être
hanté par le parti conservateur et le
bloc québécois il y en a un vase des
vases communicants pour parfait
évidemment notamment en raison de la
souveraineté mais quand même des vases
communicants entre ces deux partis là et
donc plus heureux nos taux montent plus
c'est difficile pour le bloc québécois
s'est pas actuellement tout à fait
visible mais la tendance et les quand
même là d'un sondage à l'eau depuis le
mois d'octobre puis on disait hier qu'il
avait de la difficulté mais surtout dans
plusieurs duos y montre au québec ses
positions plus nationale et s'entend pas
de conditions la langue française croit
que hier sur la nomination des juges à
la cour suprême et c'est absolument pas
engagé à nommer des bilingues mais il
dit je m'engage à ce qu'ils apprennent
le français josé vos impressions sur les
les intentions de vote fédéral au québec
le piège pour le parti conservateur m
avec un chrono tout c'est justement
c'est que l'on va te reste
habituellement concentrées en région
c'est pas nécessairement si c'est ça
c'était pas très payant pour stephen
harper ça sera pas plus pour monsieur
autour mais bon on verra en temps et
lieu là où ces ruses et inconfortables
c'est pour le premier ministre du québec
françois legault
alors justement à ça dans sa ronde de
négociations avec justin trudeau sur les
transferts en santé où ça se passe pas
bien du tout et monsieur autour lui fait
de l'oeil politique comme quand vous
venez de dire c'est là et monsieur
legault va être pris entre l'arbre du
bloc et les corses du parti conservateur
est ce qu'ils voient enfin chez un petit
peu plus d'un côté ou de l'autre faut
pas oublier qu'à la dernière élection
fédérale le bloc québécois s'était
transformé une littéralement jupons de
françois legault là il illustre aîné
donc moi c'est ce que je vais surveiller
se situe d'échec à surveiller la der
monsieur le guen entrevue lundi avec
nous je posais beaucoup de questions là
dessus puis à l'essai à peu près toutes
les portes ouvertes
michel david oui bah les conservateurs
tiennent pas mais sympa premier partout
au québec
eux ils vont en faire comme ça peut
marcher la dernière fois mais la
stratégie c'était d'identifier un
certain nombre de comtés et de mettre le
paquet là-dessus gars n'ont eu seulement
10 à l'arc dans leurs espoirs les plus
fous il se voyait déjà
c'est un peu c'est un peu trop mais
envisage une vingtaine de députés par
exemple je pense que monsieur otto
serais très content et on voit déjà deux
qui sont assez solidement première place
à québec dans la région de québec
alors comment dire le pays caquistes ils
ont ils ont pas mal de raisons d'espérer
la progression est belle et là ça fait
juste commencé et je tomberai clame ce
logo garde toutes les portes ouvertes
mais moi je suis convaincu que plus ça
va aller et encore plus les négociations
monsieur trudeau continent est aussi du
sel plus sans doute son jupon on va
dépasser à monsieur legault n'est pas
fait un peu
des remarques espace où tout à fait et
le bloc que monsieur trudeau monsieur
vous dit c'est que le vioxx
nancy peut y trouver quelqu'un d'autre
pour avancer mais ce trudeau il faut
savoir que ça surtout intentions de vote
au québec monsieur legault trombe dans
ce cas pas de doute verbe 49 pour cent
d'appuis légère diminution
les libéraux remonter de 4 % légère de
remonter il n'y a pas eu d'effet au
parti québécois légère baisse mais n'a
pas eu d'effet avec le nouveau chef et
québec solidaire qui est à 11 pour ça
vous impression jean joseph père de
joseph baisse et ce à écouter monsieur
legault de toute façon ils trônent seuls
au sommet depuis l'année dernière sa
part commencé avec la pandémie
oui le remporter l'élection en 2018 avec
37,5 pour ça des voix mais dès 2019 ça
s'est remis à grimper et même pendant
l'happy le pire de l'hécatombe dans les
ca social dès cette année c'était du 48
e du 50 pour ça aussi
et chez les francophones parce
qu'aujourd'hui bon et à 49 % au québec
mais chez les francophones ses 57 pour
ça c'est énorme alors ça laisse rien aux
partis d'opposition
on connaît toutes les raisons monsieur
lebon été très habile dû occuper tout le
terrain politique et dans la pandémie
ben la confiance qui existait déjà avant
la crise s'est consolidée parce que bon
une grande partie des québécois ont
choisi de lui faire confiance à savoir
vous faire confiance on peut voir le
tableau rapidement il ya une bonne note
comme docteur arruda d'ailleurs
étonnamment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
critiques envers dr arruda mais ils se
maintiennent quand même avec des bonnes
mais monsieur dubé la milice fédéral
puis monsieur trudeau qui était moins
bien notés par les québécois
commentaires surtout ça allait qu on se
demande s il
hésitation autour des rassemblements de
noël on les perd mais on ne permet pas à
les écouter des points politiques à
françois legault la réponse est non
autant dans les intentions de vote et
dans le taux de satisfaction que dans sa
cote personnelle clairement les gens qui
ont compris pourquoi elle a décidé de
revenir en arrière au gouvernement ce
qui ressort beaucoup je troll de ces
sondages là qui s'accumulent c'est les
québécois en général ont l'impression
que le gouvernement fait de son mieux il
françois legault fait de son mieux que
la situation est compliquée puisque de
reggae il regarde ce qui a comme
alternative qui se disent pas que
dominique anglade pas c est pierre
plamondon bien rire a nato du brauman
omar sy ferait beaucoup mieux dans la
situation actuelle tant que ça cette
perception là ne changera pas pour
françois legault on est en position de
commande ceci dit il reste plus de 18
mois avant les prochaines élections la
politique c'est tout sauf prévisible
mais ses claques à tout prendre entre
françois legault mettons et la position
de jason kenny en alberta qui est rendu
à 30 % de taux de s'instruire chuté de
rien brutal spectaculaire même bien il
va certainement prendre sa position à
l'approché de noël à une paix dit que
numéro 1 en alberta
oui bon les élections c'est d'un peu
moins de 2 à 6 e km oui mais quand
monsieur leubou regarde ça je pense
qu'il doit très très content évidemment
49 pour salon frise les 100 députés
avaient avec des scores comme ceux-là
mais il aussi regarder ce qui se passe
derrière lui les partis d'opposition il
ya madame anglade qui a réussi quand
même à faire remonter son parti de
quelques points
ça c'est pas une grosse menace pour
monsieur legault s'est pas c'est pas la
folie du héros qui pourrait
théoriquement aller chercher des comptes
et au pakistan serait d'inès d'autres
nationalistes et le pq au premier chef
mais le pq recule alors pour monsieur
legault ça c'est extrêmement bon bon 4 à
québec solidaire
ça devient un peu inquiétant là parce
que d'un sondage à l'autre il ya rien d
grignote ils perdent les lois et on on
peut voir le jour où ils vont être
retourné sur lui
à vous trois je crois qu'on ne reverra
pas avant l'année 2000 21
parce qu'il me reste demain alors merci
et à très bientôt puis je vous souhaite
de joyeuses fêtes malgré ce contexte
difficile pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i see
her dit